cbs news has learned there may be a
justice department investigation into
former president trump's handling of
documents when he left office according
to the new york times workers from the
national archives found
possibly classified information among
the documents recovered from the
mar-a-lago resort ed o'keefe is at the
white house for us ed good morning to
you the mission of the national archives
is to preserve and provide access to
federal government records they've got
some unusual ones they found there in
mar-a-lago that's right tony good
morning and the concern now isn't not
only how the former president handled
national security secrets but whether
the justice department is going to have
to wade into what would immediately
become a politically divisive case
according to the washington post among
the items found in those 15 boxes of
records recovered from mar-a-lago were
letters between former president trump
and north korean leader kim jong-un a
letter left for trump by former
president barack obama and that map of
hurricane dorian that trump altered with
a black sharpie to falsely claim he
hadn't been wrong about the storm's path
he might remember that in a statement
the former president says he's had
collaborative and respectful discussions
with the national archives and this is
important a source familiar with this
situation tells cbs news that just
because the issue is being referred to
the justice department doesn't mean
there's actually going to be a criminal
investigation or potential prosecution
the source adds that this is a standard
procedure in the event that people think
there may have been a criminal violation
but dana all of this reminder that more
than a year after leaving office the
former president continues to face a
world of legal issues
yeah and add that map very hard to
forget thank you